AI has transformed the way we live work
and interact with technology from
virtual assistants to autonomous
vehicles AI is revolutionizing every
industry promising groundbreaking
advancements and unimaginable
possibilities
but why should you consider a career in
artificial intelligence AI is not just a
passing Trend it's a seismic shift that
is reshaping our world and creating new
avenues for Innovation and Discovery by
embracing a career in artificial
intelligence you become a part of a
dynamic field that thrives on solving
complex problems pushing boundaries and
making a profound impact on society the
demand for AI professionals is
skyrocketing across industries from
Healthcare and finance to entertainment
and transportation organizations are
actively seeking talented individuals
who can harness the power of artificial
intelligence to drive their businesses
forward but what does it take to become
an AI engineer how can you embark on
this thrilling Journey Don't worry we
have the answers to all your questions
hello everyone and welcome to Simply
lose in this video we'll take you
through the roadmap of how to become an
AI engineer but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you Dave also press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply love if you want to accelerate
your career in Ai and machine learning
the postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning in collaboration with
Caltech University is clearly the right
choice for you expertise in machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision and reinforcement learn you will
receive a prestigious certificate
exclusive aluminum membership and ask me
anything sessions by IB with three cap
students and 25 plus industry projects
using real data sets from Twitter Uber
and moon you will gain practical
experience master classes by Celtic
faculty and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education
simple learns job assist help you get
noticed by top hiring companies this
program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural network computer vision Gans
Keras tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunity
the link is present in the description
box below so without any further delay
let's get started some steps are crucial
to master the field of AI and becoming
an AI engineer so let's go through them
real quick first establish a strong
foundation in mathematics and
programming start by gaining a solid
understanding of critical mathematical
Concepts such as linear algebra calculus
and probability additionally it is
crucial to become proficient in a
programming language like python which
is commonly used in Ai and develop your
coding skills
next pursue a degree in relevant field
earn a bachelor's or master's degree in
computer science data science AI or a
related discipline to acquire a
comprehensive understanding of AI
principles and techniques then acquire
knowledge in machine learning and deep
learning familiarize yourself with the
male algorithms neural networks and deep
learning Frameworks like tensorflow and
pytorch to train and optimize models
using real world data sets afterward
engage in Practical projects gain
hands-on experience and demonstrate your
skills by working on AI projects
building a portfolio of projects that
showcase your ability to solve AI
problems can make a strong impression on
potential employers
collaborate and network engage with AI
communities attend conferences and
participate in online forums to connect
with Professionals in the field
collaborating with others can enhance
your learning experience and open up new
opportunities
the next part is seek internships or
entry level positions gain practical
experience through AI internships or
entry-level roles in industry or
research institutions this will provide
valuable exposure and help you further
develop your skills continuously learn
and adapt in the fast-paced world of AI
it is crucial to stay updated on new
developments explore specialized areas
and embrace emerging Technologies and
tools continue learning and adaptability
are essential for pursuing a successful
career as an AI engineer
now that you are familiar with the steps
involved in the Journey of an AI
engineer let's have a look at the salary
of an AI engineer
according to glassdo the average
reported salary of an AI engineer in the
United States is around 105 000 per year
however in India it is around 9 lakh 33
000 rupees per annum these figures are
way better than the average salary of
any job rule let's move forward and
discuss the essential skills you need to
become an AI engineer these skills
include strong programming abilities
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
Proficiency in statistics and
Mathematics familiarity with deep
learning Frameworks and experience with
big data Technologies excellent problem
solving and analytical skills are also
crucial as an AI or machine learning
engineer you need to perform certain
tasks such as developing testing and
deploying AI models through programming
algorithms like random Forest logistic
regression linear regression and so on
the responsibility of an AI engineer
includes convert machine learning models
into application program interfaces so
that other applications can use it build
AI models from scratch and help the
different components of the organization
such as product managers and
stakeholders understand what results
they gain from the model
build data ingestion and data
transformation infrastructure automate
the infrastructure that the data science
team uses perform statistical analysis
and tune the results so that the
organization can make better informed
decisions
set up and manage AI development and
product infrastructure be a good team
player as coordinating with others is
must so that's all we had for you in
this video we can call it a wrap now if
you still have any questions or doubts
let us know in the comment section below
and a team of experts will help you at
your list thank you so much for being
here today we'll see you next time until
then stay safe and keep learning with
simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here